In this lesson we will talk about viruses and internet worms. Let's first
define what a virus is, and then define what a worm is. A virus is
effectively an infection of an existing program
that results in the modification of the
original program's behavior. A worm is code
that propagates and replicates itself across the network.
A worm is usually spread by exploiting flaws in existing programs or
open services whereas viruses typically require
user action to spread. For example, opening
an attachment on an email or running an executable file that a friend gave
you on an USB key. Worms propagate automatically. We will focus most
of our attention on internet worms. But before we dive into the details
of internet worms, let's first talk about
the different types of viruses. A parasitic
virus typically infects an existing executable
file. A memory- resident virus infects running
programs. A boot-sector virus spreads whenever the
system is booted. A polymorphic virus encrypts
part of the virus program using a randomly generated key. So one of the key
differences between viruses and worms is that viruses typically
spread with manual user intervention. Worms
typically spread automatically by scanning for
vulnerabilities and infecting vulnerable hosts when
those vulnerabilities are discovered. A worm might
use any of these techniques to infect a particular host before spreading
further. In the rest of the lesson we will first talk about a brief history
of internet worms, including the first Internet
worm, called the Morris worm, and other
famous Internet worms from the early days of Internet worms in the early 2000's,
including Code Red and other well-known Internet worms of the time. We'll
then talk about how to model the spread of a worm, in terms of scanning and
infection rates, using analogies from epidemiology. Finally,
we'll talk about design techniques for designing
super fast-spreading worms. And we'll look at
an example of a super fast-spreading worm.